i believe the best way to improve  it's when it's playful i've seen so many  guys do i can't say names but  it's crazy how many guys i've seen that  left their career in the gyms  yeah because they spar too hard every  sparring for them it's it's about  winning the round  yeah it's about life or death you cannot  improve like this  you need to be playful of course when  you're in training camp and your fight  is coming up you need to  somehow trying to recreate that  environment of  discomfort that stress  but when you're outside of that  preparation preparation zone you need  you need to be playful because that's  when you you improve when it's playful  when it's like a game  you know because you will be more prone  to trying new things  and and by trying new things you'll  you'll adapt you'll be like oh this one  works this one  doesn't work but the one that works i  keep it in my back pocket you know and  it makes you grow